hey if you want to get some exclusive
anime merge and also directly support
this channel at the same time check out
our online store at anime Lord calm we
have original designs created by pro
manga artist Kazuma including this esken
or praise the Sun shirt and now
featuring a brand new design Mele
Otisfield a Rath link is in the
description you can use the discount
code uproar 25 for an instant 25% off at
checkout
[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about the strongest of
the four Archangels
my L and how powerful he truly is when
he is in possession of his incredible
divine grace called sunshine we already
know that at his strongest mile is
easily the most powerful member of the
entire goddess clan aside from the
supreme deity herself and in this video
I will look at all the information that
we have about mile and about the
abilities sunshine in order to determine
how strong miles full power compares to
other characters in the story including
of course Mellie Otis I am also very
interested in how mile at full power
could affect the course of the wider
seven deadly sins story both now and in
the future if you enjoy the seven deadly
sins content on this channel and you
want to see more you can leave a like to
let me know and if you're new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell now this
video we'll be looking at relevant
information all the way up to the latest
chapters of the manga so if you're not
caught up be warned there will
definitely be some manga spoilers ahead
please proceed with caution and if you
don't want any spoilers beyond the anime
then this is definitely the time to step
away alright so let's talk about chapter
two nine seven of the seven deadly sins
manga where we witnessed an incredibly
important exchange between mile and
esken or an exchange that could
completely alter the course of the seven
deadly sins story this chapter could be
setting up an overpowered showdown
between Maya and Milly auras after he
absorbs all 10 commandments although
what happens after malleolus absorbs the
commandments will depend on how
malleolus acts when he emerges from the
cocoon will the darkness from the
commandments consume him will he be
reunited with his emotions and become
good again or will he be torn between
light and darkness
anyway as esken or Merlyn do Rachelle
and the others are desperately
struggling to contain the original demon
and zelgius Miele swoops in and grabs
the severely weakened Eskin or even in
his daytime form
ESCA noir was no match for the original
demon but after recognizing mile s
kannur pleads with him to take
possession of his grace sunshine once
more in order to save his friends
the demons askin ORS amazing power
called sunshine the very power that
allows him to become so strong during
the day and reached a nearly invincible
state known as the one at noon once
belonged to my ELF however a smile tells
us the grace abandoned him when he
became one of the 10 commandments and
thousands of years later it chose s
Kannur as the ideal vessel my L doesn't
want to accept sunshine at first because
he believes that the Grays chose s
Kannur for a reason but s Kannur says
that without the power of sunshine they
cannot possibly defeat the original
demon and zelgius as strong as s kannur
is in his daytime form and we know that
he is frickin strong even he was unable
to defeat the original demon and Merlin
and Ludo shall haven't been able to do
it either so the big question is how
strong will mile be when he regains
sunshine the divine grace that was
originally created specifically for him
by the supreme deity herself while his
body was still corrupted by the multiple
commandments that he had absorbed miles
power level was over 200,000 on the one
hand the commandments definitely gave
him extra strength but the commandments
were also eating away at him from the
inside which made him weaker and more
mentally unstable in the long run now
that he has gotten rid of the
commandments regained his memories and
cleared his head
we know that miles should be extremely
powerful especially because he is
currently in his original goddess body
he is not just possessing a much weaker
human body like the other goddesses have
been doing for most of the story so if
we take into account the fact that he is
in his original goddess body and that
his mind is finally clear how strong
will Miele be as he regains possession
of sunshine well let's look at what we
know about mild thus far during the
previous holy war miles strength was
compared to the strength of meli otis
and after meliodas switched sides and
decided to join the alliance against the
demons the original goals are decided
that the only way to stop the demons
from being completely destroyed was to
manipulate the memories of everyone who
knew miele including male himself and
make him take meliodas his place as the
love of the ten commandments as soon as
they lost mile the goddess clan no
longer had a chance to defeat the demon
clan outright so they were forced to
sacrifice their own physical bodies in
order to temporarily seal the demons
away inside the coffin of eternal
darkness if sunshine can make Eska nor a
mere human go from the lowest accurately
measured power level of only 15 in his
nighttime form which is also the lowest
power level that has been accurately
measured in the entire series to the
invincible incarnation of power at noon
each day then it is reasonable to assume
that Miele with sunshine could actually
be much stronger than ESCA nor with
sunshine
we know that mile is infinitely stronger
even without sunshine than Eska nor is
in his nighttime form when sunshine is
not active and we also know that
sunshine can make Eskin or gold from a
power level of 15 to a power level of
probably 200,000 or even more so it
isn't too much of a stretch to think
that Miele with sunshine could be a lot
stronger than
Eskin or with sunshine by the way the
highest that s canora's power has been
measured in his daytime form is 114
thousand but that is only because his
power fluctuates so wildly that it is
difficult to accurately measure his full
power and potential however based on his
feats during the most recent arc in the
manga and how he has performed against
enemies like Zell drous and the original
demon I would place his power level at
least around 200,000 although when s
Kannur is in his state known as the one
his power for that brief period of time
could be much greater but again there is
just no way to accurately measure the
one so how strong will mile be now that
s Kannur has asked him to take
possession of sunshine at least
temporarily and how is this going to
affect the rest of the story in terms of
power level it is really difficult to
say for sure how strong Maya will become
because as I mentioned earlier we do not
have an accurate measurement of Eskin or
power level in his daytime form and we
also don't know for sure what miles
power level is without sunshine we just
know that his power level was over
200,000 when he still had the
commandments inside his body my personal
guess is that miles power with sunshine
will easily surpass 300,000 if we assume
that
and learn kusik combining into the
original diamond combines their two
power levels into one then
Chandler's 174,000 plus ku Sox 168,000
equals 341,000 and that is assuming that
as the original diamond the two power
levels simply combine rather than
multiply on top of that we recently
learned about the original diamond
special ability called crisis which
actually increases his power the more
damage his body sustains I think that my
Elle with sunshine will be instrumental
in ultimately defeating the original
demon and if I'm right and mile with
sunshine will be the one to take down
the original demon then his power level
will have to rise well beyond 341,000
however even if Miele does defeat the
original demon possibly with the help of
Merlin King and the others it seems
clear to me that the original demon will
not be the final boss of the series
after all we still have zell drous who
cannot be underestimated we still have
the demon king and of course we still
have Mele auras and we don't yet know
how absorbing the 10 commandments will
ultimately affect his personality will
he be the same notice that he was before
will he turn completely evil or will he
be something in between it is important
to remember that in spite of my personal
educated guesses there is one major wild
card involved in all of this and that of
course is the nature of sunshine itself
this ability is incredibly unstable and
we know from ESCA NORs example that the
power of sunshine fluctuates wildly
during the day so wild in fact that its
power cannot be accurately measured and
in his ultimate state known as the one s
kannur power became so immense that the
mere heat he generated could seriously
hurt people around him and this state is
also known to put a heavy strain on s
canora's own body as well so the
question is how will miles use of
sunshine differ from SK Knorr does the
fact that mile has a goddess body rather
than a normal human body mean that he
will be able to use sunshine more
efficiently than Eskin or because his
body won't be as easily strained by the
power of sunshine
does the fact that sunshine was
originally created for mile mean that he
will be able to control it more
effectively than eScan or so that he can
use its maximum power or even the one at
other times of day and not just at noon
all of this is still a mystery for now
and I am really curious to find out
what's going to happen next in the story
but I personally think that the original
demon as powerful as he is will indeed
be defeated by my L with sunshine let me
know if you agree down in the comments
and be sure to tell me what you think is
about to happen next in the story I have
to say that the character of mile has
now become one of the most interesting
characters in the entire seven deadly
sins series for me personally and that's
saying a lot when you consider how many
great characters this series has Miele
starts out as someone who believes that
all the demons are filthy impure
creatures and that he would be doing
them a favor by killing them this is
simply the belief system that Miele was
brought up in the goddess clan and even
his own brother Ludo shell instilled in
him this message of hate towards the
demons at a very young age during the
previous holy war we saw how members of
the goddess clan tried to kill all of
the demons and they were even willing to
kill their own allies such as the humans
if they so much as decided to help a
demon even if that particular demon
didn't do anything wrong
so they were clearly extremists and
members of the goddess clan who rejected
this extremist approach including
Elisabeth Jenna and son re were forced
to pay a terrible price Elizabeth was
cursed by the supreme deity for daring
to fall in love with a demon and Jenna
ensign airy had to possess the bodies of
humans in order to hide from the goddess
clan because they were considered to be
traitors for refusing to support the war
so mile grows up in this environment of
hatred towards the demons and the
goddess clan convinces him that they are
fundamentally superior to the impure
demons but then thanks to the powerful
magic of the original goal thir Maia
loses his memories and identity and he
becomes esta rosa the love of the ten
commandments mile the strongest of the
four Archangels becomes a member of the
demon clan that he hated so much for his
entire life and his own grace sunshine
abandons him after one of the demon
Kings commandment
enters his body this leads to mile
becoming a split personality of sorts as
his inner goddess nature and the
darkness of the commandment are in
constant war with each other
Esther OSA / male becomes increasingly
mentally unstable until he transforms
into one of the best villains in the
entire series in fact for me personally
as to Rosa / male has been the best
villain that we've seen in the seven
deadly sins so far however miles
development doesn't end there after go
through and the others finally get
through to him Maya refuses to allow the
commandments to tear him apart from the
inside and he banishes them with this
smile finally regains his memories and
reverts back to his original goddess
nature but without his divine grace
sunshine which was at the time in the
possession of Eskin or even at this
point Miele is conflicted he realizes
that he spent 3,000 years as a demon
something that he was taught all his
life to despise and as a demon he did
many horrible things that he cannot
fathom we are left wondering what ismail
going to do now is he simply going to
fly away and leave the war and
everything else behind him is he going
to return to the extremist ways of the
goddesses and decide to kill every demon
he can find as a revenge for what
happened to him or is he going to see
the truth which is that not all demons
are bad and not all goddesses are good
it is far more complicated than that at
this point in the story it looks like
Miele is waking up to the truth and he
has decided to help the others fight
against the original demon because he
wants to be good and do good things the
fact that Eska nor is willing to return
sunshine 2-mile tells me that esken or
senses that miles heart is now pure and
that he is truly going to do his best to
help save Eska norse friends and
everyone else honestly myles character
arc has been an amazing one and his
development as a character has been
exceptional I seriously cannot wait to
see what happens next and I'm looking
forward to hearing all of your thoughts
about what is going to happen act in a
story down in the comments if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more you can leave a like to let me know
and if you're new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell if you want to get
exclusive anime merch and support this
channel at the same time check out our
online store anime AFRICOM link is in
the description also
in case you don't know we have a weekly
anime podcast called rant cafe where we
bring a bunch of youtubers together and
talk about all the different things in
the world of anime and manga you can now
listen to rank a fail on Spotify iTunes
and anywhere else that you get your
podcasts just search us up our a and T
space CAF P a big THANK YOU to Trudeau
17 and de la mancha 2 for allowing me to
use their awesome seven deadly sins fan
art in this video I will link both of
their deviantART accounts in the
description be sure to check them out
and show them some love as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see you space cowboys
[Music]
you